enjoy this man's work on the today show
on msnbc as well i listened to him in
the car
and his new book uh pops learning to be
a son
and a father is perfect right now
certainly on father's day weekend and
father's day week wherever books are
sold
craig melvin here on the rich eisen show
how you been craig
rich so good to come on so good to be a
part of this
this peacock synergy yes indeed um
during father's day week
i have been a fan of of your work for uh
many years as well so
um good to finally talk to you exactly
and it was a pleasure being able to tell
that to you to you in person when i ran
into you at the super bowl uh
a couple of years ago what's you what's
your team craig what's your
what's your what's your sports teams
what are you would you show
in 1988 back when um
the nfl teams used to travel for the
preseason to cities that didn't have
major teams um in 1988 the thin
uh washington football team um
they traveled to williams bryce stadium
there was a
a guy under center named doug williams
who
who looked like me uh who my father
adored um and
after seeing the redskins and the bills
in 1988
i became a washington fan and then fast
forward to
2008 uh when i moved to washington for
for work at the nbc station there
and i met my uh my now wife
um covering she was covering the the
washington football team at the time um
i met and fell in love with a sports
anchor um
and the first story i saw her covering
was a washington football story i knew
it was meant to be then
and we've been washington football fans
ever since right
yeah i know and you and i are similar
like that i've i met my wife in
espn newsroom and um you know fell in
love with her
and you know uh watched her with a
terrific career
in uh in television sports as well and
lindsey zarniak is your your wife
correct craig at last check that was
correct correct
great good to know that has confirmed
terrific and so you're both children
yeah it's how many
how many kids do you have okay we have a
seven-year-old
and we have a four-year-old um my
seven-year-old just went to soccer my
four-year-old is
is uh when we're done here i'll take her
to swimming
we pretty much run a shuttle service uh
for little people
kind of kind of what we do you used to
have free time and watch movies and
drink wine and
and now we don't drive around uh in
greats
[Laughter]
well was that was that the original
title of your book correct
driving around in grades is that you
know what that was actually my pitch
and the publisher came back and they
were like um i don't know if people are
gonna buy that
i call them narcissists in my house
craig susie and i call them narcissists
every now and then how old are yours uh
12
10 and seven so my youngest is your
oldest
oh yeah holy smokes but it is the
greatest thing i mean
it is the greatest thing and you know
and one thing that you know my wife and
i
uh talk about and sometimes do tell
certainly our oldest is that there's no
there's no um handbook pretty much on
learning to parent you know we're all we
all can obviously take from the
the you know the roots of our tree best
we can
but when it all comes down to it in real
life in real time
um you're kind of sometimes fumbling for
the light switch
and you know i i think that's what your
book
in part is about craig yes we are
all learning on the fly and i would
contend
uh rich that each generation does a
little bit better
than than the previous uh my dad
you know i and i write about in the book
in fact the first line
of the book is you know my dad was born
in a
prison in west virginia in 1950 and it's
not something that i knew growing up
but certainly not something that we
talked about um
and the ways that can can shape and mold
you um
you you don't fully appreciate and until
you're much older so my
my dad um was a jail baby as
as the kids called him um when he was
little he didn't know who his father was
until he was almost a teenager and
in the book i i interviewed my dad for
more than four hours
and one of the questions i asked was
what's the most money you ever wasted
and without missing a beat my dad said
about twenty four hundred dollars in
nineteen eighty six
that's twenty four hundred dollars
mentioned what was that on he's like
that's what it cost to put my father in
the ground
he he did not know his dad um
and when he when he did finally sort of
get known later in life
um he didn't like him very much
um and so they didn't have much
relationship
so then fast forward to my you know my
dad becomes a father
he doesn't have a great playbook rich
and and so
he he did the best that he could
i did not fully appreciate that he was
doing the best that he could
until i sat down to write this book um
my father
suffered with a couple different
addictions and um
but consequently wasn't the best dad
growing up and then all of a sudden
uh in in the in the third quarter of his
life if you will
um late 60s he decides to finally
uh pick himself up and dust himself off
and and and start a new path and it's
it's a
it's a remarkable story it just happens
to be you know my dad's story and so i
wrote this book to try and do some good
craig melvin of the today show and pops
learning to be a son and a father here
on the rich eisen show
so um for those who are hearing this
story for the first time um
and those who might have a similar um
story to tell how do you how do you
parent how did you figure out how to
to parent did you utilize some of the
things that you didn't
like about what happened to you as a kid
and said i'm going to
steadfastly avoid this or how did you
how did you grab the handbook and
playbook there was a little bit of that
um i i've always believed that you can
be motivated by negative examples
more than positive examples in many
instances and that was the case
you know the picture of a father that i
saw i i didn't know
you know precisely the kind of man i
wanted to be or what i wanted to
to do with my life but i i know that you
know for the better part of 20 years the
father that i saw i didn't want to be
that um and that that did motivate me
but but but more than that i had a lot
of
a lot of men and women by the way
uh along my journey who stepped in
uh to fill those voids um uncles
and teachers and coaches
uh and my mom you know my mother uh god
bless her and
i i've write a fair amount about her in
the book as well
um my mother like a lot of mothers out
there in this country unfortunately
had to play the part of
of mom and dad for a good chunk of my
life
um and you know she she did it it was
without complaint and and when you're
young you don't
you know you don't realize what's
happening around you
and when i sat down to to work on this
book i
i interviewed my mother as well for
hours uh
which both of the interviews my mom and
my dad when people ask now you know what
what's your favorite interview that's
always a big question
um hands down one and two uh
mom and dad in that order but um my
mother
picked up a second job at one point
because you know
my dad's uh drinking addiction
his addiction to alcohol gave way to
another addiction an addiction to
gambling video poker
in south carolina in the 80s and 90s was
all the rage it became quite the scourge
uh on many families it was finally
outlawed
um but for a number of years you could
go and and
and sit in front of a screen and um
and feed you know dollar after dollar
into this
like video pokemon my dad would um
you know every other friday get his
paycheck he'd belly up to the video
poker machine and have a
a tall boy budweiser in one hand and
he's pressing the buttons
uh in the other and my mom would send me
and eventually my younger brother
and or um we'd go in there in the
afternoon and and
uh we tried to negotiate some of my
dad's paycheck before he squandered all
of it
um and and so during that time my mother
really put put our family on her back um
and and supported us uh financially
emotionally uh spiritually
and it's it's it's not something that 13
or 14 year olds can fully appreciate
and then all of a sudden as you know uh
rich you start to have your own children
and you you
you view parenthood differently
and i became
more aware of the sacrifices that both
of my parents
were making um when i when i started to
compare my own to well craig congrats on
the book man
pops learning to be a son and a father
your beautiful family on the cover
uh as well um i wasn't able to read it
from cover to cover is there something
in there about crying at everything now
that you're a father
is there something what commercial
actually
there is
[Applause]
[Laughter]
there is something there is something in
the book about how being a dad
uh turns you it turns into a big pile of
mush i know i cried
i cried insurance commercials i don't
know what i sometimes think about what
the hell's happening to me
i i don't you know we're we're more
tinder than what you said i i would
i would i would argue it's a good thing
of course
absolutely it did i am i am so glad
and i know it's been you i'm so glad you
left espn
what a what a blessing this has been
for for all of us at the peacock i
appreciate that
i appreciate you saying that craig um
yeah i appreciate that kick that up the
chain of command
go for it i will and it's the good thing
you got out before the place went to
hell
craig that'll be for our next book
together is this live this isn't live
this is this this thing on it's yeah
it's like by the way
i feel like i'm shannon sharp i should
tell you that you're on the air you know
like
you know this has been live the whole
time you take care of yourself craig
congrats on the book
let's do this again be well you got it
that's craig melvin
at craig melvin i follow him on twitter
you should as well on instagram at
craigmelvin
nbc that one took a turn at the very end
greg's got someone in his house who
knows what you've been through that's
right
mutually parted way
oh it's kind of i'm so naive sometimes
or collected
connected dots yeah hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here